- The thing that I remember the
most from that Super Bowl, man,
was the fact that I almost
didn't even get to play in it.
- What happened in the
NFC Championship Game?
- In the NFC Championship game, second
quarter—you work your whole life
for the opportunity to play in the Super
Bowl, right? And to get to that point,
go to make a tackle against
the tight end, and he jumps up;
the first thing I do was put my arm
out, and his knee caught my arm,
and my arm lost that battle.
♪♪♪
- [Master Tesfatsion:] So who
we got in the pool hall today?
Thomas Davis. What's up, baby?
- [Thomas Davis]: What’s good man?
- How retirement treating you, man?
- I can't complain.
- How nice are you on
the pool stick, man?
- I mean, I'm all right. I ain't the best, but
I been watching the show, so I definitely
know that I can take you down.
- Man, go ahead, bro.
Let's see what you can do.
- Let's see, man. I can't mess this up.
- [Laughing]
There you go.
We’ve never had that happen before.
- Eight on the break! Man, that's a, that's—
- We’ve never had that happen before!
- That's a win, baby!
- A win? That's a L!
- That's a win!
- Where you from?
- From Georgia.
- This must be some, some Georgia-Texas differences, man.
- It's a dub. That's a dub.
- Nah, bro.
- Hey, make sure y'all keep, make
sure y'all keep that. I need that.
- What part of Georgia you from?
- From South Georgia, man, down...a
little small town. Shellman, Georgia.
Population probably about 900 people.
Not a lot of people know about
Shellman. It's like south of Atlanta.
- So playing high school, I mean,
how many offers you get, then?
Being in a small town like that.
- Funny you ask that. So in high school
I played eight different positions.
- It wasn't nine-man or
nothing? Or was, was it—
- Nah, it was 11-man football.
- [Laughing] OK.
- But it was one of those things where
I was the best player on the team, and
Coach wanted to put me in the position to
be successful. So eight different positions.
And when I say that to people, people think,
like, “OK, it was eight different positions
over the course of your high school career.”
No. It was eight different
positions per game.
- Just like that Spice Adams, talking
about linebacker, what else you play?
- Exactly. I line up at receiver. I play
quarterback. I play running back.
And I did all of those things. I
was the kicker. I was the punter.
I was the punt returner. I think doing
that may have ended up hurting me
more than it helped me because teams
didn't really know how to recruit me,
where they would play me
at. But I got an offer from
a Georgia coach coming in,
watching me practice basketball.
- Damn. Having an offer from
Georgia, being in Georgia.
- You know, being a hometown kid, you
grew up, you watching the hometown team.
And to get that offer, I, I really
didn't even know how to take it.
It was some doubt that started to creep in.
But once I got there, you
know, I made my mind up that
nobody at Georgia was gonna outwork me.
So I went from the last
guy given a scholarship
to the first guy drafted out of the 30
kids that went to Georgia that year.
- You got 16 despite the fact
that you had to overcome three torn ACL
surgeries in three consecutive seasons.
- That’s why I feel like, you know, when
we made it to the Super Bowl in 2015,
that was supposed to be the year
that kind of capped off everything
that had already happened
over the course of my career.
- Take me through that Super Bowl.
Was it Super Bowl 50, right?
- Yes.
- Levi Stadium. Panthers. Broncos.
You're facing Peyton Manning.
What do you remember from that night?
- The thing that I remember the
most from that Super Bowl, man,
was the fact that I almost
didn't even get to play in it.
- What happened in the
NFC Championship game?
- In the NFC Championship game,
man, in the second quarter—
you work your whole life for the opportunity
to play in the Super Bowl, right, as a player.
And for me it was 11 years at that
point. And to get to that point,
and in the second quarter go to
make a tackle against the tight end.
Me and Luke are closing in
on him, and he jumps up, and
the first thing I do was put my arm
out. And his knee caught my arm,
and my arm lost that battle. I broke my arm.
Trainers come out. They asked me like,
"What are you thinking?" I'm like,
"Man, it's broken.” We go in the back.
Everything that we know about injuries
and know about having broken bones,
there's no way that in two weeks I'm gonna
be able to play in the Super Bowl
- None.
- after breaking my arm. But then
we go in at halftime, we go look at it,
and they were like, "Look, we can
do surgery at six in the morning
and you can play in the Super Bowl, but it's
really gonna come down to a pain tolerance
on whether or not you can
play the whole game."
- When was this conversation happening?
- It was literally at halftime. And then—
- Halftime of the NFC Championship
Game. Who you guys playing?
- We played against the Arizona Cardinals.
We go in after we won the game, and they
and they reassured me that, "Hey, if you can
deal with the pain of what's gonna come
after you have this surgery, you can play in
the Super Bowl." That's all I needed to hear.
- So next morning you have
the surgery in Charlotte?
- Yes.
- Recovery, everything, and then from that
point on what's the rehab process like?
- The portion of my arm that
I broke was the ulna, and—
- You can still see the scar, too.
- Yeah. The scar's still there. Like, and I
still had this little tissue that they cut into.
So the portion that they cut into was,
like, what really controlled your grip.
That was the hardest thing that I had to
work through over the course of those
two weeks to get the grip strength back. We
go from that doubt and that uncertainty of
being able to play in that Super
Bowl, to not missing the snap.
Like, which is, which is unheard of.
- At one of the most physical, if not the
most physical, position of the game.
- Once the opportunity presented itself,
I'm out there, I'm playin' in this game,
and we just gonna see what happens.
Defensively, we had a great game, man.
We had a great game plan, and we
playin' against arguably one of the best
quarterbacks of all time, and
he didn't beat us. I'll say that.
He didn't beat us. They won the
game, but he didn't beat us.
- I had $500 moneyline on y'all, bro.
- Von Miller.
- Bro.
- DeMarcus Ware. Hats off to
those dudes, man. I told Von,
"Man, you got my Super Bowl
ring," every time I see him.
- [Laughing]
- Give him a hard time, man.
♪♪♪
- Now Thomas, you trying
to go for the high score.
It’s 191. We’re gonna see how you do.
Sixty seconds. But I’m gonna be
asking you questions. You ready?
- Let’s do it. I got this.
- Three.
[Digital beeps from game sounding]
Two, one.
Who’s the best linebacker
in the NFL right now?
- Uh, Bobby Wagner.
- Favorite QB to sack?
- Drew Brees.
- Toughest coach you’ve ever had?
- John Fox.
- Was it more fun playing
safety or linebacker?
- Safety.
- Best defense right now in the NFL?
- The Rams.
- The Rams! Hardest QB to sack?
- Mike Vick.
- Worst fans in the NFL?
I need to hear this one.
- The Chargers.
- The Chargers. They ain’t
got nobody. [Laughing]
Which barbecue is better:
Carolina or Texas?
- Carolina.
- You trippin’. I’m gon’ let that slide.
North Carolina or South Carolina?
- North Carolina.
- OK. Cam Newton: fashion
master or fashion disaster?
- Uh, master.
- Hardest guy to tackle?
- Adrian Peterson.
- Super Bowl matchup
prediction, who you got?
- Tampa and KC.
- KC. You got a rematch?
- Rematch, rematch.
- Brady or Rodgers, who you like?
- Uh, Rodgers.
- Best linebacker of all time?
- Ray Lewis.
- This year’s MVP, who you got?
- Mahomes.
- Dirtiest opponent you’ve ever faced?
- Sweezum. J. R. Sweezy.
- [Laughing]
Funniest teammate you
ever had? Ten seconds left.
- Oh, man. Probably Cam.
- Best city to visit on the road?
- Seattle.
- Pregame meal snack routine,
whatchu eat before a game?
- Pasta.
- Three, two, one. Oh! You got 194! You
still fell short of Lisa, though, man.
- God. Dang.
-  You got the high score
on this one. 194. Thomas.
- Hey man.
- Ay, appreciate you for coming out bro.
- Miss Leslie, you still the champ.
- [Laughing]
- Hats off to you.